my buddy from way back in the day for
many years at the nfl media group now
with bally sports he does a beautiful
podcast with his daughter called the
pass it down podcast joining me here on
the rich eisen show my friend michael
silver how are you michael
great rich how are you hanging in there
let's get right into this with both uh
both feet since
uh you were the one to essentially break
yesterday that odell was not there
because the team was told by the browns
he's essentially no longer part of the
team and now it's another day of stay at
home what is happening with o'dell in
cleveland best you can tell
well rich it's a weird stare down
because the trade deadline is over so
people keep saying well they're
negotiating with o'dell
not sure what there is to negotiate uh
they could have traded him before the
deadline uh probably could have gotten
maybe a sixth round pick and figured out
who paid what of this year's salary but
um
they
let that deadline lapse and you know
from what i have been told by players
and coaches rich he has not acted out
overtly there is not an incident that we
don't know about um that's public in
that facility where he did something
obviously his father had the social
media post lebron james at the social
media post and there may be something
going on behind the scenes that maybe
just occurred between him and kevin
stefanski or him and andrew berry but if
so
i don't know what that is but
clearly kevin stefanski and the browns
seem to have decided
we can't have this enough of this but
um you know you can't really do the old
uh john gruden keyshawn thing from back
in the day in tampa for old people like
us who remember where
they got into a place where john gruden
was basically like go away
and
you're just not gonna be part of the
team this year you'll get your money
but
you're gone uh you can't really do that
anymore under the the current cva so
unless they can figure out a way to
suspend them for conduct detrimental of
the team they kind of have to make a
decision and that's why i'm not sure
what they're negotiating it seems like
he's going to get released so that's the
whole sense of things when somebody's
excused from absence i mean an excused
absence you're excused from practice you
may stay home
it's it's um
it connotes that the player has done
something
you're saying that the player has done
nothing
well i don't know if the player has done
something the players and coaches i
talked to didn't know of anything he had
done other than you know his father
posting
very obscurely on social media that he
thinks the quarterback sucks and you
know
i unless they're keeping him away and
saying you can come back if you come
you know eat it and apologize and do
this and that which i i don't know that
either this is just me you know
wondering but um
kevin savanski took a pretty
extraordinary step he gathered the team
together yesterday and said basically
odell's not on our team anymore and you
know he's not here today we sent him
home
and let's proceed accordingly so
i i don't see
you know the likelihood of a solution
where he's back there uh you know given
that statement michael silver bally
sports here on the rich eisen show so
is this a situation where
they don't want him to get hurt and then
they're they're they're on the hook for
all this money and they've decided he's
not on the team anymore and and odell's
just got to sit at home i mean i
i don't know well i don't understand
that like or or they are they're gonna
or they're gonna say that his shoulder
is hurt so bad he's now he's now put on
ir and and come
come with your grievance is that
literally what they might actually do
too
something like that yeah i mean i guess
you could try to do that and then you
know let them file a grievance but you
you know you're technically not allowed
to do that now the texans and deshaun
watson are essentially doing that but
it's with the players um you know
cooperation right he's like cool pay me
i don't want to play for you i don't
want to practice if if desean watson
shows up today and is like hey man i'm
healthy i'm your fourth string
quarterback or whatever you say i am i
want some reps then they
you know that's at a crossroads too um
but
you know it sounds like odell showed up
for practice and was like all right i'm
here and they decided not to but
yeah to me it's not just oh we don't
want him to get hurt because
he has no value to them anymore they
don't want him to play for them and they
didn't trade him so
i don't you know yeah you'd be on the
hook for the money but i think you're
gonna have to release them and be on the
hook for the money anyway so maybe
they're trying to get him to agree to
not join a certain team or you know i
again i i don't
i'll try to find out in these coming
hours and days i don't understand what
there is to negotiate it seems to me
like they missed their window which was
the trade deadline to get anything and
now
if they don't want them they probably
have to cut them and zoom last one for
you on this what's your sense that of
what baker feels about all this his
sense of everything and the relationship
between them on the football field what
we do see
on film that hasn't been edited by
odell's dad you know like what do you
think is going on
there well i mean i mean it's funny
because
you know
these are human beings and i think fans
tend to
even when they're dealing with human
things you know turn them into
caricatures i mean you know i i put a
joking tweet out about uh the dolphins
chris greer the general manager's
statement about tua yesterday which is
no no no he's our guy we were just
looking around and i said you know try
it out with your spouse which is not
an original thought but it applied here
and then you had the literal police
saying you know
oh
this is nothing like a marriage and it's
like yeah but
i still would argue that you know human
beings who have a job and are proud and
trying to perform it every day when they
know their bosses are clearly
trying to replace them with someone they
think is better
that's something you have to deal with
it's not insurmountable but it's a thing
so yeah
it's a thing when baker bayfield who's
trying to win games and is kind of
struggling and has a you know contract
extension on the line and his future
has a high-profile guy who uh has odell
beckham senior posting something that
sure seems to be an attack and
you know odell's not calling him right
away junior saying man my dad's crazy
that's horrible i just cut him out of my
family or whatever you would say so
yeah it's a thing now
um you know they they seem to have
bigger problems than that i i've talked
to people
uh inside that building one person told
me i'm close with both of them
i you know very close with both of them
and this didn't have to happen i hate
that it's happened and i i i'm kind of
struggling with the fact that there's
this much of a disconnect and
um you know it does seem to be largely
about football uh odell is a proud guy
who like many receivers wants the ball
and thinks he's open and thinks he can
help the team that way and uh you know
baker i'm sure would tell you i'm trying
to run the offense for everyone and do
my job the best i can and i don't know
the football side of it you know this
year enough to
uh in that building to understand whose
side i should take but
i do know that it's got to be affecting
baker on a human level so they this per
let's uh let me pull on that strand a
little bit more said it
it didn't have to happen what's the it
the posting of the video this week that
uh
i think well this was a coach who said
that and i think that i think but what
didn't have to happen was kevin
stefanski getting to the point where he
told a team at a meeting uh he's not on
the team anymore that that's what i was
referring to wow man
uh it is just remarkable because
normally again something like this
happens there's a blow up there's this
somebody said that and that either
that's not getting out or it's just as
you're saying that didn't happen
[Music]
[Applause]
someone referenced uh in 1996 which i
have a very intimate familiarity with
andre rison
had been in jacksonville and
uh he and tom coughlin butted heads over
not football over some
you know managerial type things who was
the alpha i remember because andre told
me the entire story uh at a
green bay
uh quote club which is really a bar uh
one night in 1996 after he'd been cut
and arrived in green bay and told me a
very detailed story which is one of my
favorites ever and it was later
corroborated by
multiple witnesses but he got cut
uh the packers who were trying to get to
the super bowl and had receiver injuries
signed him and he ended up being a huge
player for them you know
and route to a championship so you know
if odell beckham is waived then people
can put in waiver claims he doesn't get
to choose his own team but if he clears
waivers or uh you know nobody decides to
claim that contract watch out he might
be able to pick his team and uh he he
may we may see him in february yeah i
know certainly if he plays for safe
baltimore he might wind up in cleveland
again yeah but wearing purple you know
and that's probably what that that's
that's exactly what i think this is
about to be honest with you michael at
this point now that he's at home i'm
sure i'm sure it is i just don't know
that they
you know they they lost their right to
determine that this season
by
the trade deadline passing so
uh that's why i'm confused by the time
mike silver here on the rich eisen show
um so
i'll give you the floor on aaron rodgers
i guess uh to borrow a phrase of yours
that you once uttered famously uh the
lip reader seeing standing next to aaron
wtf uh mike what do you think what's
your thoughts on the subject well okay
first of all um you know i would
urge people to follow the science and do
what's best for your community and
i'm certainly vaccinated and uh i don't
have a chip in my ear i have a much
better
chance of surviving covet and i
as i have trusted experts
since before i could formulate a
coherent thought uh when i took all
those vaccines as an infant uh that have
helped me stay healthy i you know that's
where i stand on it um you know and look
um
first of all i
i tweeted in late august
when he said the thing about yeah i'm
immunized um i said is being immunized
the same as being
vaccinated because it felt weird to me
his phrasing and i know he's a smart guy
who phrases things you know who knows
what he's saying now if you go back and
look at the statement it wasn't just the
word he clearly was giving the
impression in my opinion
yeah i i took care of that and so
um you know i think journalists were
maybe too quick without a follow-up to
say
he's been vaccinated but i also think
aaron wanted to give that impression um
you know the nfl and the nflpa
negotiated rules
um
that were very clear for people who
aren't vaccinated and you know with
health and safety in mind but also i
think you know wanting to
make it clear that if you're gonna go
this route you're going to have some
conditions placed on you that people who
go the scientifically sound route
don't and
he didn't seem to in front of us follow
those rules so that's an issue too but
you know i guess i would say first of
all i haven't heard back from aaron i
first of all i hope he's okay it's a
correct crazy lousy horrible thing that
is i know any lies i know yeah that's
what so i didn't want to you know i know
a lot of people were immediately like
he's a liar that i can't believe you did
this to his team the packers should be
in trouble like it's fair to talk about
all of that and we're going through this
as a nation and a world and it sucks and
everybody has a right to feel strongly
about it but yeah i guess let's first
you know hopefully he's okay and comes
back strong and and uh
you know we can we can all debate this
uh the way we should no i i agree with
you on that um i i i and
you know
it it stinks that he's out of such a big
game like this and it stinks that he's
got it and um you know
if he was vaccinated you know
he'd have a shot to play this week even
though i've yet to hear somebody who was
vaccinated who did test positive that
suddenly got two negatives in a row
um you know but put it all together
though the thing that i'm looking about
over the steering wheel
is is how the reaction from uh the
packers and how it got out that he did
stuff holistically and things like that
like where did the and how aaron's gonna
probably take all that you know i i'm
i'm i'm looking into
the future and wondering if we're gonna
start because he was telling me when he
came on the show earlier this season
about a month ago about trust and hope
and he trusts and and puts his hope in
the packers and things were going so
well i mean he was the owner of the
bears and the general manager of the
packers all at once with
with uh two straight in a couple
straight weeks you know um
so how do you think he's going to take
all this you know assuming he gets back
healthy as we all hope he does what do
you think he's been a d he's been a
decent gm by the way because you know
the randall cobb signing or trade which
everyone laughed at he made some pretty
big catches you know i like the
aggressiveness jalen smith didn't work
out they signed merciless i mean keep it
coming i wish they had wished they had
taken a swing at the training deadline
yeah um no it's a fair point rich they
were in such a bad place and
um i'm wondering if they're going to be
back in that same place again like it
comes
the holistic medicine and he's trying to
he's trying to make that something
similar to actual vaccination which he
calls immunization and you know we we
all understand he was playing with words
there
you know
it's not their fault though i mean i i
hope he
you know you could i you know i'm on his
side when it comes to a lot of the
disconnect between him and the front
office over the years
and i i just you know this is not the
packer's fault this is uh you know he
he made his own bag
he made a decision they didn't overtly
call attention to it if anything they
helped him you know
act as though he was vaccinated from
what i could tell and um you know even
matt lafleur now is certainly who you
know has a great relationship with aaron
but he's not trying to throw him under
the bus i mean mike zimmer got upset ron
rivera got upset we've seen coaches get
upset and frustrated when people won't
get vaccinated they don't seem to be
doing that but i think you're right i
think you know the way they're behaving
and will behave speaks to that
sensitivity and so um probably they will
uh you know just be kind of uh you know
they'll they'll just throw up their
hands and take their punishment from the
league but i i don't think you're gonna
see them
uh you know make a strong statement
about how
you know people need to follow protocols
that's really important michael silver
here uh on the rich eisen show and then
lastly um
what what did happen best you can tell
with desean watson not going to miami
and stephen ross actually still meeting
with desean watson you made mention
earlier in this about chris greer the
general manager the dolphin statement of
everybody putting the
humpty dumpty tua back together again
right here um with everybody sitting
here thinking they're going to just be
playing out a string to try and get to
another crack at watson
right yeah i mean they're they're
clearly not all in with two uh and
listen you know as with trubisky right
who came in the same draft as mahomes
and watson and actually went way before
them you know i mean tua came after burr
okay well burrow went one but he's been
really really good and he came right
before herbert and you just can't ignore
it i mean the guy's been
you know from the start uh has been you
know a a
a potential superstar and so
um yeah they're not all in with him by
any means um and i don't think that
changes as far as watson i mean to me it
was always complicated i'd read these
reports where it said well the texans
anything less than three ones is a deal
breaker and i'm like yeah you might be
you know not understanding your leverage
guys uh with all due respect like i mean
now don't get me started on that
dumpster fire of an organization which
by the way my first story for bally
sports was about uh chair cal mcnair
dropping a little uh china virus
commented
the public realm back in may uh you know
and sneering afterwards so you've got
him you got jack easterby you've got uh
with that when when toronto taylor is
out you've got one of the worst football
teams i've ever seen in my life taking
the field although they play the
dolphins on sunday so uh that'll be a
test and and so
you know look um it's a messy
complicated situation and it's a lot of
compensation the owner has to be willing
to handle that stuff in the community
because there's some pretty you know
creepy allegations you've got the
outstanding lawsuits you've got the
threat of criminal
prosecution and then you've also got the
league possibly suspending them or
putting them on the commissioner's
exempt list so to me why didn't it get
done because if you're going to give up
all that you want some degree of
belief that the mess is getting cleaned
up and i guess they wanted them to
settle all the civil lawsuits which is
probably tricky and that didn't happen
so to me that's probably why that and
the combination of the texans being like
look man we don't care about all that
stuff he's desean watson if you want him
you got to pay and i i i never it never
made sense to me that a team would give
up all that for a guy
in that situation michael silver bally
sports the pass it down podcast with
your daughter thanks for coming on the
program
thanks a lot rick you bet that's mike
silver right here on the rich eisen show